[Music]
sometimes they say oh a kid did it it's
not worth anything
lots of people say that 12 year olds are
such an annoying age
critics say that i'm like jackson
pollock
and i say it is a compliment but i want
to be known for my own style not being
compared to someone else
[Music]
this great big story was made possible
by lego play her way
[Music]
my name is elita andre i'm an abstract
painter and i'm from melbourne australia
at only 12 years old elita has been in
the industry for over a decade
i started painting when i was nine
months old my dad put a canvas down on
the floor because he used to paint a
little bit
i just started crawling on the canvas
and started painting before him
that's how everything started that was
my first painting
[Music]
my first show was at the age of two
years old
without telling the gallery owner her
age her mother presented the work and
elita was booked for her first show
since then she has taken her art across
the globe and has sold paintings for
around 35 000 us
dollars i've been to london russia japan
new york italy china
mumworld
hong kong
but four times
i paint every few days but mainly when
i'm inspired
when i paint i usually think about the
universe i think about animals pretty
much everything that has to do with
nature
[Music]
with the violins on the canvas i want to
show that the whole universe is singing
although elite is young she understands
the harsh critics in the art world
when people question my talent usually i
don't mind because i think that everyone
should have their own opinion
but there is one critic whose opinion
does matter so fluffy is our little pet
heart critic he usually starts biting me
or biting the painting if he doesn't
like it
[Music]
my mum and dad encouraged my art and i'm
so happy
so i definitely think that i'm going to
be doing painting for the rest of my
life it's something that i love so much
[Music]